avant de démarrer ce talk j'aimerais
juste précisé que j'ai eu une enfance
très heureuse
mes parents ont toujours été très
attentionné ils nous ont toujours
soutenus dans nos choix
je dis cela parce que tout simplement et
puis j'aimerais en profiter le plus
longtemps possible encore j'ai ça pour
ceux qui parmi vous dirai à la fin du
tome celui-là il a dû avoir des
problèmes dans son enfance alors par
rapport à la demande de sa là c'est vrai
que ça fait trois ans que je refuse
moi j'ai pas traversé de demers je n'ai
pas franchi de montagne je me disais
mais qu'est ce que je peux bien lui
apporter je veux bien encore comprendre
que à des moments j'ai pu influer sur
sur sa vie ou sur la vie d'autres
personnes mais que puis-je à porter et
puis il m'a obligé à bosser mais bosser
c'est à dire j'ai je suis allé chercher
au plus profond de moi qu'est ce qu'il
pouvait faire que j'avais quelque chose
aujourd'hui à apporter est aussi loin
d'aussi loin que je me souvienne je me
pose toujours un tas de questions
pour ceux qui me connaissent j'adore
poser des questions avoir des réponses
et surtout ce que je préfère c'est que
les réponses amène à d'autres questions
et ça c'est certainement ce qui dans ma
vie à a généré le plus de richesses
aujourd'hui en recherchant comme ça par
rapport à ce qu'il m'avait demandé j'ai
repensé une question 40 et toute mon
enfance
enfin une partie raisonnable cette
question c'est tout simplement est ce
que tous les humains voie de la même
façon je passais mon temps observé je
regardais est-ce qu'on voit tous de la
même façon c'est sûr et puis avec le
temps j'ai en plus appris que les
animaux ne percevait pas du tout le
monde comme nous alors c'est devenu
encore plus obsessionnel et puis
aujourd'hui avec un peu plus de recul
sur la vie
j'ai le sentiment que la vraie question
c'est que voyons-nous qui n'existe pas
j'ai la chance d'avoir une enfance dans
une tradition juive avec des touches de
culture catholique du côté de ma mère
alors quand vous êtes enfant ça c'est
très enrichissant
je voulais vous le conseille d'abord il
ya plus de fait en ce moment c'est le
nouvel an juif
alors vous faites deux fois le nouvel an
dans l'année c'est quand même plutôt top
vous avez aussi rannou qu'à noël donc
des cadeaux en tous cas des cadeaux à
noël c'est toujours bon à prendre
vous avez évidemment peyssard pâques etc
je vois tout voulait faire et par
rapport à cela
je crois que c'était certainement ce
qu'il m'a enrichi le plus et qui m'a
permis aussi d'une manière ou d'une
autre de comprendre ce que voulait dire
tolérance et au fur et à mesure que j'ai
grandi ce qui était perçu comme une
richesse devenait un malaise une gêne un
jour j'ai posé une question à mon rabin
je lui dit rabih c'est qui jésus m'a
regardé et m'a dit un juif tout
simplement stop et là j'ai compris j'ai
compris une chose essentielle c'est
qu'il y a une ligne invisible
il y avait une ligne invisible entre des
personnes qui ne portait pas le même
regard les uns vis-à-vis des autres tout
simplement ce qu'ils avaient une culture
religieuse différente et moi cette ligne
invisible
je l'avais jamais vu je n'avais jamais
vu parce que de temps en temps j'étais
d'un côté et temps en temps j'étais de
l'autre côté
au cours de mon enfance j'ai appris
qu'il y avait plus que des lignes
invisibles
il y avait des frontières invisibles les
frontières invisibles j'ai découverte à
l'école à l'école j'ai passé mon temps
entre rebellion et soumission rebellion
soumission j'ai eu plus souvent le
sentiment de me soumettre ou raciaux et
par rapport à cette vision
l'enjeu numéro un ce que j'ai perçu
c'est que l'école créer des frontières
invisibles
elle crée des frontières entre les
garçons et l'ici j'ose même pas imaginer
si j'étais né une ou deux générations
avant quand les garçons les filles
étaient séparés elle crée des frontières
invisibles
entre l'individu et le collectif j'ai
une image comme ça en mai mois où on
faisait des dévs ou des devoirs sur
table et on devait séparer avec des
classeurs pour pas de copier sur le
voisin il ya une chose qui m'a toujours
paru absurde la frontière invisible
entre science art culture littérature
sport ça n'a pas de sens moi je rêve
d'un prof de physique qui vient dans ce
port m'expliquer comment faire entrer un
ballon de basket
voilà parce que le prof de sport elle a
eu du mal dans les faits il ya deux
frontières que je ne supporte pas la
première frontière c'est entre
l'ignorant et sachant le sa chance et
celui qui enseigne ignorance et celui
qui est en face
et moi j'ai jamais pu supporter qu'on
pense qu'un enfant est ignorant je crois
par principe au contraire qu'un enfant a
beaucoup à nous apprendre
parce qu'un enfant c'est un regard neuf
sur le monde et puis enfin la dernière
frontière qui est insupportable c'est la
frontière entre la réussite et l'échec
la réussite et l'échec qui en france en
plus se situe à 10 quels dégâts nous
avons fait avec les personnes que nous
avons fait échouer à 9 95
et puis moi j'ai beaucoup appris à
travers les chèques et j'ai aussi
parfois compris que certaines réussites
noter que des échecs le plus difficile
quand j'ai fait cette introspection pour
pour le ted
le plus difficile a été de me rendre
compte que je critique c'est ligne
invisible ses frontières invisibles mais
dans les faits je me suis rendu compte
que j'étais un bâtisseur de murs
invisibles
j'ai bâti des murs invisibles
après de longues longues études j'avais
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de questions
qui pas eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
réponses j'ai eu une réponse essentielle
au cours de mes études j'ai rencontré ma
femme c'est le plus important
après de belles expériences entre des
voyages à l'étranger et puis des
entreprises
j'ai décidé d'entrer à l'université
pourquoi tout simplement parce que pour
moi l'université c'était un lieu
d'expression un lieu de liberté
ça me correspondait on est en 2000 en
2007 le nouveau président de
l'université pour qui j'ai beaucoup de
respect beaucoup destine par rapport à
son intégrité me demande de venir le
seconde et j'accepte j'accepte de
devenir le premier vice président de
l'université
c'est une période très spécial pour moi
elle est spéciale parce que à double
titre d'abord vous avez l'impression que
vous allez faire beaucoup de choses
c'est parti vous allez pouvoir engager
un changement
et puis c'est une période spéciale pour
ceux qui s'en souviennent parce que
c'est le moment où les universités
devienne autonome
qu'est ce que c'est l'autonomie c'est
après des années des années des années
de revendications
nous voulons la liberté l'état vient et
dites vous l'avez alors là évidemment
c'était une aubaine jeu j'étais en
situation de dire voilà on va faire des
choses on travaille pour une juste cause
pour l'avenir et j'étais d'autant plus
enthousiasme sur enthousiastes sur cette
période pardon que d'une certaine
manière j'ai l'intimé conviction je le
dois à l'institution en tout
toute modestie je dois la france et on
va assez vite déchanté on va déchanter
pour une raison assez simple on nous
donne la liberté mais on n'a pas grand
chose on n'a pas d'informations fiables
c'est par comment fonctionne
l'université on a pas de tableau de bord
vous n'êtes pas obligé de le répéter on
n'a pas de d'adhésion c'est à dire que
vous avez beaucoup de personnes qui sont
sur la réserve sur la défensive
ça je le découvre moi j'adore avancé
voir de nouvelles choses et là je me
retrouve avec des personnes qui sont sur
la défensive
et puis évidemment on a aussi un état
qui fait un pas en avant deux pas en
arrière
trois pas en avant un pas en arrière
saft un tipi ça simplifie pas les choses
alors pour compenser on va travailler on
va énormément bossé
on va bosser 10h 12h 14h par jour on va
travailler six jours sept jours sur sept
on pense que c'est c'est nous qui allons
trouver la solution on pense que la
solution étant nous mêmes mais en même
temps dans le même moment je sens qu'on
s'enferme je sens qu'on s'isole
alors je vous présente jonathan jonathan
c'est mon fils et on est un matin au
petit déjeuner à cette période il avait
à peu près ces tâches que vous voyez sur
la photo il me me parle me dit papa il
ya un problème avec ma bouche
alors je sais c'est cesser ces moments
où d'abord on en parle tout âge et plus
quasiment plus le petit déjeuner et
encore et j'entends cette voie elle
vient de loin elle vient de très loin et
pire encore je crois que je le vois pas
mon fils je ne le vois pas et je il doit
répéter je sais pas combien de fois il a
répété en fait jusqu'au moment où j'ai
entendu cette voix
je les ai entendus je me suis essuyé et
il l'a répété encore gentiment et là je
me suis énervé j kouadjo quoi et avec la
même voix la même petite voix sans vie
sans aucune aucun tremblement rien il
m'a dit papa tu as bouche elle a perdu
son sourire
il m'a pas dit papa tu as bush
pardon papa tu ne sourit plus m'a dit
papa tu as bush a perdu son sourire on
n'a rien à apprendre des enfants est là
en un temps record tous les murs que
j'avais construit ses murs invisibles
que j'avais construit entre moi et ma
famille entre moi et mes valeurs entre
moi et la vie tous ces murs se sont
effrités effondré quelques mots ont
suffi et j'avais un nouveau regard
j'ai démissionné
je me suis consacré exclusivement à la
direction de la faculté qui était une
grosse composante de l'université
j'étais y avait un sentiment de
culpabilité
j'avais un sentiment de culpabilité
voire de lâcheté d'avoir abandonné
l'équipe mais je me raccrocher à cette
idée que j'allais pouvoir faire des
shows j'étais sur le terrain
j'allais faire des choses j'allais
pouvoir avancer on allait gagner
et en fait pendant un moment ça a bien
fonctionné
d'abord je sais que j'étais très bien
entouré j'avais des équipes
administratives et des équipes
pédagogiques remarquable j'avais des
gens avec qui je pouvais partager
développer des projets développés des
diplômes tout allait bien mais l'ondé de
choc provoquée par jonathan avait brisé
plus de mur qu'il n'y paraissait j'avais
un nouveau regard et j'étais en train de
prendre conscience d'un phénomène qui
est latent qui est présent le malaise de
notre jeunesse
j'ai vu
clairement il y a un problème
nous avons un problème avec notre
jeunesse je ne sais pas ce que nous
avons fait je ne sais pas comment nous
en sommes responsables
vous avez peut-être écouté au début de
la semaine
le rapport de l'unicef la france est un
cas particulier
43% des jeunes sont en situation de
grande souffrance de grande détresse
comment en est on arrivé là
hélas ce qui m'a encore plus convaincu
qu'il y avait un problème un matin j'ai
reçu un mail d'une ancienne étudiante
on reçoit souvent des mails de nos
étudiants qui nous remercient qui nous
informent de leur carrière et c'est très
agréable dans notre métier mais là
c'était un mail d'une jeune fille qui
avait eu une carrière brillante qui
avait fait des études brillantes et qui
était en burn out
je me suis retrouvé dans cette situation
où je me suis même interrogé sur les
objectifs que nous avions
j'ai voulu faire avancer les choses j'ai
commencé à vouloir articulé revoir le
système
et là je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait des fils invisibles dès qu'on va
au delà d'une certaine frontières dès
qu'on va au delà d'une certaine limite
des fils vous retiennent c'est le
système qui ne veut pas évoluer le
système veut se reproduire et nous
sommes des agents de cette reproduction
il ne veut pas changer alors j'ai pris d
un ciseau et j'ai commencé à couper des
fils je n'ai pas eu le courage de couper
tous les fils et je le regrette
peut-être mais j'en ai coupé une bonne
partie à ce stade je n'avais pas la
solution
je me posais des questions mais je
n'avais pas la solution
c'est lui qui va m'apporter une partie
de la réponse je vous présente sacha
alors c'est charlie né avec l'ipad
merci apple il est né avec l'ipad et là
dessus il fait du sel fille à un petit
comique 1 et ils avaient pris l'habitude
de mettre des fonds d'écran sur tous les
ipad les ipod les iphone et pendant une
bonne partie de cette période j'avais
cette photo sous les yeux ça vous donne
de l'énergie
ça vous fait sourire surtout dans
certaines réunions
mais dans les faits il m'a il y a eu un
moment où je me suis rappelé un
événement quand il était petit cet
événement il
il était assez anodin il avait 5 ans il
savait ni lire ni écrire savait juste
écrire sache et je le trouve sous google
earth jeudi mais sacha tu fais quoi
et il fait 10 je cherche tous les
endroits du monde qui porte mon nom
heil a pas du tout à fait comme ça je
vous rassure mais c'était à peu près ça
il avait en fait compris qu'il était
citoyen du monde
citoyen du monde patron tiers pas de
ligne pas de murs et là je me suis dit
la clé elle se situe là dessus il faut
travailler là dessus il faut laisser ces
générations s'exprimer il faut qu'elle
puisse s'exprimer
c'est le plus important il faut qu'elle
soit créative il faut qu'elle soit
imaginative alors avec des amis avec le
concours de la cci la mef et de
l'université on a créé enough campus il
neuf campus c'est notre garage de
lamelouze valais je dis souvent
voilà c'est là où les uns y vont on leur
dit oui allez-y créer pourquoi créer
parce que créer c'est faire disparaître
ses fers s'est effacée des lignes
invisibles créé n'arrêtait pas de créer
ensuite on a développé avec le
l'université aussi le cnam le service
civique un programme qu'on appelle pose
qu'est ce que c'est que ce programme en
fait ce programme il est la destination
des jeunes qu'on appelle des décrocheurs
je n'aime pas ce terme là moi je préfère
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont ce
sont des jeunes qui sont brisées
pourquoi ils sont brisés par ce qu'on
leur dit tu vois la porte là bas il faut
que tu la teigne vas-y marche
il passe la première porte passée la
première porte on lui dit il y en a une
seconde mais là il faut que tu ailles un
peu plus vite elle va se refermer cours
et y court
et puis il y en a une troisième est là à
ce moment là on dit tu vois la porte la
suivante là bas alors les foutus cours
encore plus vite et le gamin est court
jusqu aujourd hui se tape une porte
il sait même plus pourquoi il court il
sait même plus pourquoi il passe ses
portes
on a une jeunesse aujourd'hui qui ne
s'interroge même
ces choix parce qu'on leur dit qu'il
faut aller vers cette porte est le plus
dur dans l'histoire c'est qu'arrivé à
cette porte certaines se ferment et les
jeunes c'est game over
game over le système couplé fils c'est
intolérable
c'est absolument insupportable et nous
on a décidé que ces jeunes à qui on
avait fait game over que le jeu
commençait seulement que parce que ses
fils maintenant été coupée eh bien ils
pouvaient s'exprimer choisir leurs
portes
ce programme va certainement être des
plus déployé sur toute la france
et puis on s'est pris à rêver on a créé
15 0 en est en train de créer
alors on rêve de km 0 c'est quoi c'est
un lieu où il n'y a pas de frontières
c'est un lieu où les gens travaillent
sans qu'il y ait la moindre le moindre
mur la moins de frontières la moindre
ligne
on veut des lieux magiques on veut des
lieux où l'ignorant apprend en sachant
on vieux des lieux où le manuel apprend
l'intellectuel on veut des lieux où en
fait la technologie apprend la science
c'est ça qu'a m 0 et on peut tous
réaliser ce rêve
alors si je me suis aujourd'hui dévoilé
devant vous et si j'ai partagé avec vous
mes convictions les plus profondes
c'est pour ma fille alors ma fille
évidemment et toute la génération toutes
les générations qu'elle représente en
fait cette génération est là le monde
entre ses mains
ma fille mon coeur j'ai répondu à une
des questions qui hantent est mon
enfance je ne sais pas si tous les
humains voient le monde de la même façon
et je ne serais certainement jamais par
contre ce que je sais c'est que l'image
qui est transmis à nos yeux
et cette image que nos yeux de
transmettre à notre cerveau et bien
cette image est déformé parce que notre
cerveau l'interprète ils l'interprètent
à travers un long long long processus
d'apprentissage dans ce processus
d'apprentissage
on introduit des lignes invisibles on
introduit des frontières visibles on
introduit des murs invisibles
ainsi il va falloir que tu apprennes à
désapprendre il faut d apprendre il faut
effacer les lignes invisibles
il faut franchir les frontières
invisibles il faut détruire les murs
invisibles et si possible il faut que tu
coupes les murs invisibles
nous en avons tous besoin
nous avons besoin de ce regard nouveau
l'humanité est en marche
nous ne sommes qu'un maillon dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
et si votre génération veut construire
le maillon suivant alors elle doit
regarder à travers ses propres yeux pas
à travers nos yeux merci à tous chana
tova est très bonne année